[Música]
familias brasileñas enterraron los
cuerpos de sus allegados que murieron a
causa de las intensas lluvias y
deslizamientos de tierra en la localidad
de petrópolis donde el número de muertos
supera al centenar y se espera que
aumente además más de 300 personas
debieron abandonar sus hogares
'ecuador reglamento la despenalización
del aborto en casos de violación la
medida permite la interrupción del
embarazo hasta la semana número 12 para
las mujeres mayores de edad que habiten
en ciudades y hasta la semana 18 en
menores o en mujeres que reciban en
zonas rurales ampliaremos desde quitó y
por orden de un jueves del expresidente
de eeuu donald trump y dos de sus hijos
deberán testificar en la investigación
cíclica delante al estado de nueva york
sobre las prácticas fiscales en los
negocios del exmandatario
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
informativa de france 24 dedicada a las
principales noticias del continente
americano soy santiago lista y
comenzamos esta emisión en brasil donde
iniciaron los entierros de las personas
que murieron a causa de las intensas
lluvias y deslizamientos de tierra en la
localidad de petrópolis los allegados
asistieron a un cementerio para despedir
a sus seres queridos y dejar flores en
sus tumbas el número de muertos supera
ya el centenar y se espera que aumente a
medida que pasan las horas del panorama
en esta ciudad del estado de río de
janeiro no mejora además de las pérdidas
de vidas más de 300 personas debieron
abandonar sus hogares y una gran parte
del municipio quedó destrozado
todavía no parece cierto es algo que es
muy difícil
mañana el día era hermoso y esperaba la
lluvia aún sigue siendo difícil de
expresar la situación por la que estoy
atravesando
y la asamblea nacional de ecuador
reglamento la despenalización del aborto
en casos de violación la medida permite
la interrupción del embarazo al hasta la
semana número 12 de gestación en el caso
de mujeres mayores de edad que habiten
en ciudades y hasta la semana número 18
de menores de edad o en mujeres que
residan en zonas rurales la corte
constitucional había aprobado en abril
de 2021 la despenalización del aborto
por violación pero el legislativo
ecuatoriano debía reglamentar lo desde
quitó nuestro corresponsal gustavo
ortega nos amplía la información
con 75 votos a favor 41 en contra y 14
abstenciones la asamblea nacional cumple
así con la sentencia de la corte
constitucional que expuso la defensoría
del pueblo a la presentación de un
proyecto de ley que regula el acceso al
aborto en casos de violación y la
temporalidad para acceder a la
interrupción del embarazo la asamblea
nacional hizo una diferenciación de 12
semanas para mujeres que habitan en la
ciudad y para mujeres que habitan bajo
condiciones excepcionales en las zonas
rurales para niñas adolescentes y
mujeres de las nacionalidad indígena de
18 semanas para la interrupción del
embarazo argumentando la falta de
métodos de salud de primera mano para
las mujeres que habitan en las zonas
rurales los profesionales de la salud
deberán confirmar que se encuentran
dentro de las semanas autorizadas para
realizar el aborto se establecen reglas
específicas en el caso de personas con
alguna discapacidad mental que deberá
contar con su aprobación y respetar su
voluntad los centros de salud deberán
contar con formatos de consentimiento
para que las mujeres que deseen
interrumpir el embarazo sean traducidos
al braille e idiomas kichwa y
herramientas tecnológicas adecuadas en
el caso de las mujeres con discapacidad
auditiva deberán contar con intérpretes
para acceder de manera informada si
existiera conflicto de intereses y el
violador fuera el cuidador de la mujer
violentada la mujer podrá ser acompañada
por otra persona a su cargo los centros
de salud también deberán ofrecer los
formularios atención idiomas ancestrales
y garantizar la información a mujeres de
la ruralidad las niñas y adolescentes
podrán consentir la interrupción del
embarazo de manera autónoma el ejecutivo
nacional tendrá 30 días para presentar
sus observaciones y promulgar la ley y
enviarlo así al registro civil para su
entrar en vigencia vamos ahora eeuu
porque un juez de manhattan ordenó que
el expresidente de donald trump y dos de
sus hijos certifiquen bajo juramento en
la investigación civil que adelanta del
estado de nueva york sobre las prácticas
fiscales en los negocios del magnate
republicano desde la gran manzana
nuestra corresponsal lamen sala nos
explica los detalles un juez de la corte
suprema ha dicho que ivanka trump a
donald júnior trump y el ex presidente
de donald trump tendrán que contestar
preguntas acerca de sus negocios
comerciales justo en un día en el que se
estaba celebrando un encuentro
contencioso porque los trama habían
pedido que se anularán las citaciones
que pedía la fiscal general del estado
de nueva york bien no va a ser así ya lo
ha dicho un juez los tres van a tener
que declarar porque según la fiscal
general del estado de nueva york y cito
textualmente se han encontrado valores
fraudulentos el uso de valores
fraudulentos y engañosos de su
patrimonio de los tramp para obtener
préstamos y beneficios fiscales así que
ahora deberá declarar bajo juramento
sobre estos negocios el juez también ha
dicho que ahora los trump tienen 21 días
para esta declaración posiblemente
recurran este fallo para no tener que
declarar pero en caso de que siguieran
adelante los trans tienen dos opciones
contestar las preguntas o bien
mantenerse en silencio acogiéndose a la
quinta enmienda que básicamente les
permite no autoincriminarse y mientras
tanto en canadá la atención sigue
aumentando la policía de ottawa busca
disolver los bloqueos de transportistas
que hace semanas protestan contra las
restricciones por el cob y 19 los
agentes se desplegaron en el centro de
la capital canadiense y levantaron
vallas edificios gubernamentales para
poner fin a la protesta de tres semanas
mientras los manifestantes desafían la
ley de emergencia anunciada por el
primer ministro justin crudo a comienzos
de esta semana que le da al gobierno
poderes extraordinarios para acabar con
las protestas y planean denunciar al
gobierno por su aplicación
los bloqueos y las ocupaciones son
ilegales son una amenaza para nuestra
economía y nuestra relación con los
socios comerciales son una amenaza para
las cadenas de suministro y la
disponibilidad de bienes esenciales como
alimentos y medicinas y son una amenaza
para la seguridad pública
y avanzamos ahora con noticias
vinculadas a la pandemia de kobe 19 cuba
asegura haberse convertido en una suerte
de modelo de lucha contra la variante
omicron aunque el linaje del virus se
detectó en la isla en diciembre no se
tradujo en un pico de casos ni de
muertes tan marcado como en otras
ocasiones y los expertos explican este
fenómeno por la campaña de vacunación de
la isla que fue la primera en inocular a
los niños a partir de los 2 años de edad
más detalles en este informe de gabriel
coria
resistió mejor cuba aunque la variante
omicron expertos nacionales e
internacionales opinan que si el linaje
del virus detectado en diciembre no
afectó tanto a la isla como a otros
países y ejerció menos presión sobre su
sistema hospitalario en la mayoría de
los países el pico con negras operó los
picos pandémicos anteriores sin embargo
el pico de nosotros se ha quedado muy
por debajo de los picos pandémico
anteriores lo que demuestra también que
nuestra vacuna irá a ver inmunizado a la
población ha sido efectivo en la isla
los científicos se felicitan por las
compañías de vacunación del país más del
88% de la población recibió la pauta
completa ha sido muy importante
indiscutiblemente las vacunas de un
valor gigantesco pero también la
estrategia que se siguió en nuestro país
para aplicar esas vacunas que no es lo
que ha pasado en algunos países que no
lo han hecho de una forma uniforme de
una forma intensiva otro punto a
destacar cuba fue el primer país del
mundo a empezar la vacunación masiva de
niños a partir de dos años mientras
muchas vacunas como pzifer o modernas
todavía no han sido aprobadas para los
menores de cinco años no nos
imaginábamos que íbamos a ser el único
país del mundo que iba a enfrentar la
ola de omicron con toda su población
pediátrica vacunada y que íbamos a poder
ver realmente el impacto que tenía la
vacunación pediátrica en el tamaño de la
incidencia de toda la enfermedad y eso
yo pienso que era una demostración muy
importante de en qué medida vacunar a la
población pediátrica no es solamente un
problema de proteger a los niños es
también un problema de proteger a la
sociedad de manera general cuba
desarrolló sus propias vacunas a pesar
del bloqueo económico de eeuu estas ya
se usan en venezuela nicaragua vietnam y
grant y la habana solicitará en las
próximas semanas la aprobación de dos de
ellas por la ms para que puedan
comercializarse a nivel internacional y
para finalizar esta emisión vamos hasta
chile donde una lengua indígena
desapareció tras la muerte de la última
persona nativa que él hablaba cristina
calderón última hablante nativa de la
lengua ya jaén una etnia chilena que
habita el extremo sur del país falleció
a los 93 años de edad conocida
popularmente como la abuela cristina
calderón fue reconocida por el gobierno
chileno como un tesoro humano vivo hace
más de una década por su trabajo en la
preservación de una cultura que se fue
desvaneciendo con ella se va a parte
importante de la memoria cultural de
nuestro pueblo escribió su hija lidia
calderón
es todo por el momento recuerden que
pueden ampliar estas noticias en
france24 punto con gracias por
acompañarnos y sigan con nosotros
[Música]